salut aujourd'hui je ne sais pas dans
quelle catégorie je vais ranger cette
vidéo mental mais c'est john booth brain
ac live j'en sais rien en fait mais je
pense que c'est plus avec life alors
c'est parti à claques quelque chose de
très désagréable c'est quand quelqu'un
dit du mal de vous ça agace un petit peu
et la première réaction qu'on a c'est
d'ouvert se venger au lieu de vous
venger je vous propose de guérir la
personne et de vous guérir vous-même de
small à dire du mal de quelqu'un c'était
un média sur quelqu'un ça revient à
boire du poison soi même toi tu peux te
poses on en espérant que ça fasse du mal
à l'autre personne
on comprend bien le principe c'est pas
moi qui ai trouvé cette métaphore elle
est issue du livre des accords toltèques
avec le premier accord avant une parole
impeccable c'est pas évident de s'y
tenir
la plupart du temps quand on est en
train de blablater un petit peu sur
quelqu'un se sent un petit peu mal un
peu coupable de ça alors pourquoi on le
fait très bonne question merci de
l'avoir posée parler des mauvaises
choses que fait une personne permet
d'avoir bonne conscience sur sa propre
conduite te rassure quand on parle des
autres on ne parle pas de soi même et ça
évite de regarder ses propres soucis et
ses propres incohérences des fois parlé
sur quelqu'un ça veut dire avoir un
petit peu de pouvoir sur la personne ça
donne un sentiment de prestige un petit
peu de pouvoir un peu de classe mais
c'est pas classe alors si vous voyez
quelqu'un qui fait ça tout le temps qui
parle sur les os tout le temps sur vous
sur quelqu'un d'autre vous pouvez
utiliser de petits levier psychologique
pour qu'elle arrête ça on a le droit
d'utiliser du mentalisme à l'insu de la
personne pour que la personne aille
mieux malgré elle
c'est ça paraît complètement d
anthologie comme truc mais je pense que
celle les portants d'ontologie kla on
est sûr embrouilles à pipe hollande
la première méthode que je vous propose
c'est celle du virus vous allez infecté
la personne qui colportent des ragots
des rumeurs en permanence et en
infectant elle va répondre elle-même un
virus autour d'elle qui va se retourner
contre elle
imaginons que vous connaissez quelqu'un
qui dit toujours du mal de vous tout à
fait possible c'est d'ailleurs un truc
qui m'a été dit dans les commentaires et
cette vidéo est un petit peu en réponse
à ça n'hésitez pas à me donner vos
thèmes aussi dans les commentaires je me
fis et je les note dans un petit carnet
pour infecter la personne ça va être
très simple à chaque fois qu'elle va
venir vous voir et parler avec vous vous
allez lui raconter des trucs de pouce
mais des trucs incroyables qui n'existe
pas mais des trucs monga des rumeurs de
l'espace ce qui va faire qu'à chaque
fois qu'apple colporté ces rumeurs un
peu ouf
elle va perdre en crédibilité et
puisqu'on raconte ça pour avoir un peu
plus de pouvoir et de prestige va tout
de suite arrêter de parler de vous et de
raconter des rumeurs en règle générale
tout ça va prendre un certain temps
mais c'est assez efficace alors
évidemment comme vous même vous ne
voulez pas passer pour quelqu'un qui
raconte des rumeurs ne visait personne
en particulier ça peut être tout
simplement à la latte à vue le mission
qui a eu hier sur tf1 comme quoi youtube
va être payant apparemment ça commençait
la semaine prochaine j'ai dégoûté
apparemment cette année il suffira
d'avoir vite sur 20 pour avoir le bac je
sais pas si c'est bien ou pas bien mais
en tout cas bon ça tombe bien pour nous
qui passe son bac cette année
si vous passez bac cette année sinon cet
exemple n'a aucun intérêt voyez l'idée
voulais raconter des trucs de ouf mais
très généraliste qui ne vise pas une
personne en particulier
sinon vous êtes vous même en train de
dire du mal avec mon deuxième technique
le compliment indirecte la nourriture de
lego c'est un levier psychologique très
efficace pour faire changer une personne
je vous le recommande
si vous connaissez quelqu'un qui est
toujours en train de dire du mal des
autres et s'est fait en sorte que cette
personne arrive alors que vous êtes en
discussion vous vous savez qu'elle est
là mais elle elle ne sait pas que vous
savez déjà qu'elle est là on voit encore
l'idée en fait complimenter là comme si
elles étaient déjà ce que vous aimeriez
qu'elle soit un exemple très concret si
julien avec dans le groupe alors que
julien il a toujours et répète toujours
tout ce qu'on lui dit même ce qu'on lui
dit pas dire il est toujours en train de
lire des rumeurs des ragots etc
je sais que je lis arrive moi je suis en
conversation et l'a directement je
switche parce que je sais qu'il entend
sur un nom julien c'est vraiment
quelqu'un j'ai une belle estime j'ai une
belle confiance en lui parce que tu vois
qu'on lui dit quelque chose on sait
qu'on peut compter sur lui quoi
évidemment aussi ici un jour une
trahissent et je le vivrai mal mais pour
l'instant c'est quelqu'un de droit
donnait-il dis pas du mal des gens c'est
cool
le fait d'entendre ce compliment
indirects ça va faire un travail sur
l'ego et la personne d'adapter son
comportement pour être fidèle à l'image
qu'elle croit qu'on se fait d'elle et
qui lui a valu ces compliments la
troisième technique de vous permettre de
faire arrêter la personne dans ce
processus là en tout cas elle arrêtera
ce processus de rumeurs et de ragots
devant vous et ça l'aidera arrêté à
terme puisqu'elle fait ça à dire du mal
des autres à compter des ragots des
rumeurs ça veut pas dire que ce soit en
cohérence avec les valeurs qu'elle pense
avoir à l'intérieur d'elle si vous lui
fait admettre ces valeurs là elle aura
beaucoup de mal à faire le contraire
devant vous et même le contraire à terme
je reprends l'exemple de mon julien de
tout à l'heure on pourra lui dire par
exemple tu crois pas que julien que ceux
qui disent du mal des autres ils font
juste ça pour se donner un petit peu
d'importance puis pour ôter de regarder
eux ce qu'ils font ce qu'ils ne font pas
semaine il va forcément répondre le côté
positif
donc il va admettre quelque chose
quelque chose que lui fait
habituellement donc le fait d'admettre
ça ça va casser un rituel avec vous
espérons à terme le rituel avec le reste
du monde et enfin une quatrième méthode
qui correspond à un petit peu à la
première
première c'était de le lui inoculer un
virus ebola vous allez inoculer un
placebo et celui ci il et vous allez
voir la personne vous lui fait croire
que quelqu'un raconte des ragots sur l
effet du commérage sûr ça ferait un truc
du style écoute julien je viens de voir
parce que j'ai entendu une rumeur à ton
sujet alors je m'inquiète pas je le dire
à personne parce que voilà ça restera
entre toi et moi mais il ya quelqu'un ça
m'a été rapportée de quelqu'un que tu
connais pas et je veux pas te dire qui
c'est mais qui dit que tout le monde dit
que tu dis en permanence du mal des
autres que tu balances des rumeurs des
commérages et tout est là mon gars c'est
qu'aucun triple d'une la personne prend
conscience que les autres personnes
savent qu'elle dit du mal des autres 2 2
elle comprend le mal que ça peut faire 2
3 ne peut pas dire que c'est pas vrai
puisque c'est vrai que la personne fait
ça et 2,4 si elle veut que cette rumeur
là s'arrête il faut qu'elle arrête
simplement de colporter des choses qui
sont fausses et de parler des autres
vous allez pouvoir aider des gens de
votre entourage qui font ça en tout cas
ne jugez pas ne leur en voulais passer
souvent une mécanique qu'ils ont inscrit
dans le temps malgré eux
donc la meilleure solution c'est de les
aider à aller un petit peu mieux vous
pouvez aussi leur faire lire le premier
chapitre des accords toltèques que je
vous recommande je vais vous mettre un
lien dans la description vers ce bouquin
vous avais parlé une fois il ya très
longtemps que d'athènes révélation pour
moi cela n'hésitez pas à partager cette
vidéo merci aux fêtes à tous ceux qui
sous titre ça fait un moment je vous ai
pas remercier merci beaucoup
n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en
l'air il ya une rumeur qui dit que vous
allez le faire alors j'espère que
celle-ci allait vrai n'oubliez pas non
plus de vous abonner et rendez-vous ce
week-end ciao
[Musique]